desde venezuela la patagonia argentina
el deshielo de los glaciares y cumbres
nevadas en la cordillera andina es una
realidad una situación provocada por el
calentamiento global y que empeora año
tras año desde el 2020 los glaciares
andinos han perdido casi un metro al año
de grosor y cada vez es más
seguro más probable que sea el
calentamiento generado por el hombre el
que el que genera justamente las
condiciones para este derretimiento pero
podemos decir es que sí que los
glaciares en los andes están siendo
afectados y cada vez más el 2020 fue el
año más caluroso registrado en el
planeta ya este ritmo se calcula que la
mayoría de nevados y glaciares podrían
desaparecer en un siglo en los últimos
100 años el 98 por ciento de los
glaciares andinos se han reducido y sólo
unos pocos casos excepcionales como el
del famoso perito moreno en la patagonia
argentina se han mantenido estables un
hecho dramático ya que los glaciares son
la fuente de abastecimiento de agua de
muchas ciudades como la paz en bolivia o
mendoza en argentina
a medida que el calentamiento global va
haciendo que los glaciares sean cada vez
más pequeños estas reservas de agua
también son más pequeñas entonces en un
contexto de cambio climático como el que
estamos viviendo hoy con los pronósticos
que tenemos a futuro lo que podemos
esperar es que justamente las sequías
sean cada vez más severas para estas
regiones además su derretimiento
afectaría mucho a las especies
autóctonas contribuyendo a la pérdida de
biodiversidad en los andes' aunque no es
sólo un problema regional el deshielo de
los glaciares es la principal causa del
aumento del nivel del mar junto a la
expansión térmica del océano a su vez el
deshielo de los nevados montañosos es lo
que más hace aumentar los niveles
marítimos en el mundo ya que el
derretimiento de las pequeñas cumbres
nevadas contribuye mucho más a este
fenómeno que el de los glaciares de
groenlandia y de la antártida que son
las capas de hielo más grandes de todas
algo estrechamente ligado al cambio
climático y a la pérdida del nivel de la
tierra